and now things are going to get very
very interesting as corey kluber
will try to pitch himself into the
history books while getting
the yankees a victory
and paul let's let's go over his
performance
it has been extraordinary in every sense
he's he's one batter away from being
perfect through eight innings
yeah good fastball located it well but
his slider was his bread and butter i
literally
counted two sliders and he hit the
middle of the plate with all night
i mean he has been unhittable with that
he started to work his change up and a
little later in the game it's been
effective
you know what can you say he has been
dominant and
even when he is pitching behind he comes
in with
you know pitches on the corner not
hitting the middle to play with anything
well he has been that good obviously and
these are
the batters he'll face the only guy that
has got on base is charlie culverson he
walked
and uh that walk came with one out in
the third inning
then jose trevino who was over two and
back to the top of the order willie
calhoun
will be just the first texas ranger
to face him four times that's how
extraordinary kluber's performance has
been
[Music]
and the corey kluber story is an amazing
one having pitched just one inning
last year signing as a free agent with
the yankees for one year
11 million dollars the raise and the red
sox pursued him as well
he's a two-time psy young award winner
out of stetson university
he is not your typical hard-throwing
dominating pitcher but paul he's the
type of pitcher that when he's on he's
dominating without velocity
yeah you can see early in the year he
was starting to have
you know a good slider here and then
miss you know he has consistency again
and that
is what is his i mean when you look back
at his great years
it was because he was able to
consistently throw
nasty sliders and he's done that all
night
[Applause]
well first up against the veteran
right-hander is charlie
culverson
[Applause]
and there's the strike 0-1
culverson trevino and calhoun
in the bottom of the ninth inning
on one hop to le mayhew
one away
mike i'm gonna tell you right now that
is not the play you
want as a player and a no-hitter this is
an in-between hop dj lemay who makes it
look kind of easy but i tell you what
that is a tough play to start off the
ninth inning
demeanor never betrays what's going on
on the field
always looks stoic on the mound
doesn't show emotion
and david dahl is going to pinch it for
jose trevino
[Applause]
tried to go back door misses outside 1-0
so a new batter
into the mix here with dahl
[Applause]
swinging at a miss one-on-one
[Applause]
again the change-up we're in a fastball
count coming off the bench as a pin
jitter very
hard to adjust to something off speed
one and two
[Applause]
that one is laced into right field on
the run is wade he's there
and they are one out away from a
no-hitter
i'll tell you michael there was one guy
that i was going to tell you that i kind
of felt sorry for and it was tyler wade
i mean he's not in his
natural position this ball is hit off
the end of the bat just enough
but you could misjudge it a little bit
i'll tell you a great jump
and a great play
[Applause]
well if you feel what your heart is
beating right now watching this imagine
what clovers is doing
kluber against calhoun
strike one
[Applause]
calhoun old for three struck out looking
popped to second
ground ball is short
[Applause]
ground ball to gleber torres and that'll
do it
a no-hitter for corey kluber on a
wednesday night in texas
kluber becomes part of forever
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
paul you've played in three perfect
games you almost came within one batter
of announcing the perfect game corey
kluber tonight
was absolutely magnificent
phenomenal i mean if you look at the
pitches he missed
tonight you could count him on one hand
another slider
this is a good way to end it and i tell
you what
he'll appreciate this more than probably
some of those cy young so come back
where he came from
and throw a game and i guarantee the
people in texas
didn't realize that greatness would
happen with corey kluber
in a yankee uniform instead of a rangers
uniform
what an amazing performance by kluber
and paul has mentioned what this guy has
gone through
uh the shoulder issue allowing him just
to pitch one inning last year
and then the last season in cleveland
the comebacker that essentially broke
his arm
the two cy young seemed like such a
distant memory but he has achieved
greatness on this mound in texas
man oh man that is just great he is now
part of baseball
immortality as he pitches the yankees
11th
regular season no hitter and he was
in a word brilliant
you